-Welcome to the show!
-Appreciate you having me.
-Congratulations. You are
dressed like a champion,
may I say?
-Oh, yeah, you know...
-Very dapper!
-I make suits for a living.
People don't know that about me.
-This is a suit you made?
-I made this.
Damari Savile is my company.
We got a brick and mortar
in Philadelphia.
-That -- this is very upsetting
to me that you're good
at another thing.
I don't -- I don't like that.
So this was the second time that
you were a Super Bowl champion.
You won with
the New Orleans Saints
your rookie year, which was,
of course,
their first Super Bowl ever,
as well.
And what was it like being
a veteran
compared to the experience?
-Well that first one in 2009,
I was a rookie.
And my head was spinning.
You know, we're getting ready
to play the Colts.
Peyton Manning and the great,
you know, offense they had.
And I wasn't supposed to start.
I was a Special Teams guy.
And the starter in front of me
got walking pneumonia, like,
two days before the game.
And I got thrown in
kind of the second half, and so
everything happened so fast.
I didn't even get to enjoy it.
But this time around,
being a veteran, being a captain
of the team,
being a key contributor
and everything that led up
to this year, it was
something different.
Be able to bring that to
the city of Philadelphia
is something that myself
and my family won't forget.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Fantastic. A couple of photos.
There you are.
Again, far too well-dressed.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But I have to say as when to
comes to well-dressed
in the family,
this is your daughter.
Is it Elle?
-Elle.
-So how old is Elle?
This is -- she was at the game.
-Elle just turned 4.
-Aw!
-Fantastic.
-She had her Eagle wings on.
-[ Laughs ] That's very cute.
-You know she -- in
the playoffs, she was, like,
"hey, Daddy's going
to the supermarket."
[ Laughter ]
But by the time we got
to Super Bowl Sunday,
she understood everything
that was going on.
-That's great.
-"You just won the Super Bowl."
-Oh, that's very exciting.
And I guess that would be
a nice difference between your
rookie year and now, too,
is that you have someone to --
you have kids to share it with.
-I have two kids now, yeah.
I just had a daughter
three weeks ago, so, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Congratulations. Now I...
My dad's from Pittsburgh.
So I grew up a Steelers fan.
And I was very happy
because now the Steelers,
at least for another year,
still have
the most Super Bowl trophies.
-There you go.
-Your dad was a Giants fan
and held on to being a Giants
fan for a long time, right?
-Yeah, I mean, I grew up
in northern New Jersey,
so that's Giants,
you know, country.
-Yeah.
-But he was looking for a reason
to give up on Eli Manning
and those guys, so...
[ Laughter ]
When I got to New Orleans,
he obviously became
a Saints fan.
I came up to Philly,
and there was no way.
He had to cut every tie
that he had to that team.
He did it willingly
and, you know,
after those Super Bowl
commercials,
I think he's probably thinking,
"that was a great decision."
[ Laughter ]